Barriers to 5G wireless networks are regulatory
– not technical.
While the FCC is taking steps to modernize
existing deployment regulations,
most regulatory decisions about 5G
will be made at the local level.
In California, San Jose and Sacramento
have taken vastly different approaches to 5G.
San Jose sees 5G rollout as rent extraction, charging carriers $3,500
annually to access each of its street poles.
Sacramento, on the other hand, is a model
city that has already launched its pilot 5G
program. It has 100 cell sites, expanded backhaul,
an expedited permitting process, and free
Wi-Fi in 27 parks.
Soon, Sacramento will experience wireless gigabit internet—speeds
that were previously only available via fiber.
Such forward-looking cities recognize that
private investment improves operational efficiency,
lowers costs, and increases quality of life.
Cities can reduce barriers to entry
will facilitate competition and choice.
To stay ahead, American leaders
at all levels need to streamline the rollout of 5G.
What are you most excited about in the coming 5G revolution?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.